We wanted to be kind of an escape— indoor, outdoor Oasis.
You know you're going on a little trip. You're not even in the city anymore.
Welcome to the first fully operational cannabis restaurant in the United States.
It's a 20,000 square foot former brewery in West Hollywood with a menu that includes
edibles, joints, high-tech bongs and vapes.
What our ultimate goal is is to be able to pair the cannabis with the foods.
Your Flower Host would be like a Sommelier. And we want the food servers to be versed in cannabis as well.
Lily Estanislaus is Lowell Cafe's general manager.
She says that even before it opened, Lowell received more than 800 job applications.
Everybody wants to work here and I get it, but we wanted people who
had experience and not just in smoking.
That was a lot of what I got is like, hey,
I'm an avid smoker, I have so much cannabis experience. I'm like, but have you actually worked
in a dispensary? How much knowledge do you have?
Opening a cafe that's legal, especially, is very important because it just
breaks the walls down of negative stigmas that surround
the subject that is cannabis.
Erika Soto, who is an industry veteran,
works as a Flower Host at Lowell Cafe,
which is like a waitress for weed.
When guests arrive, she walks them through their options, explains the effects of carious strains,
and advises them on proper dosage levels.
It's an environment that is loving and peaceful and we all kind of see the veil drop when people get
"stoned", you know, and it's not a violent thing.
For now, Lowell could only be located in the city of West Hollywood.
What is it about West Hollywood that is more open to something like this, you think?
They have been on the forefront of just being accepting of everything that needs to be liberated.
West Hollywood is now known as the Mecca of cannabis.
There are actually three surrounding dispensary's as we speak, and the further you go into West Hollywood,
the more you're going to find things just like us.
Because California requires that all cannabis products be tracked seed to sale,
and lab tested.
Lowell Cafe isn't allowed to make its
own marijuana infused foods or drinks.
Everything must be pre-packaged.
After the Rabbi at a nearby synagogue expressed concern
that her congregants would be bombarded with the odor of weed,
Lowell installed massive air filters and machines that spray a sent neutralizing essential oil called
Cannabolish, and lighting up a tobacco cigarette is prohibited at Lowell
in compliance with a West Hollywood law.
Lowell Cafe's license is provisional for the
first year, after which the council will decide
whether to renew it. But in the meantime,
more weed hospitality shops are coming.
The city has issued licenses to seven additional businesses,
including one that will offer a virtual reality experience, and another a day spa.
Being the first, we want to of course, set the standard and sort of
prove ourselves and prove to everyone else that this is something that can be done.
And we can just kind of spread the love through the country. Then that's for sure what we want to do.